before we get started let me just tell
you I get it I'm a [ __ ] weirdo I'll
tell you why I said that a little later
but just now know that I know Dunkirk so
Dunkirk is the new Christopher Nolan
film this one is based on a true story I
don't know how true it is to the people
concentrates on for the majority of the
movie but the situation will
circumstance in Dunkirk among world war
two that happened basically there are a
bunch of soldiers stranded on a beach
the enemy is closing in they have
nowhere to go they need off the beach
they just they got nowhere to go there's
an ocean there that tends to make for
trouble the Germans are bombing the
boats they're bombing them looks pretty
bleak for these guys talking about what
I liked in the movie first of all the
movie is gorgeous looking I saw it in
IMAX so it does that thing where when in
action scenes going down or a really
important scene boo just blows out in
IMAX and the movie has some scenes of
intensity granted a lot of the intensity
revolves around people possibly drowning
once you see it a couple times you're
like I got it people almost drowned oh
look at that another person is about to
drown and the sound when the guns are go
the first time you hear a gun go off
you're like yeah that sounds like a
gunshot it might have been this speaker
system of theater I saw it in but
whenever a gun was going off those
planes were coming in it does that that
sound effect you know just your the like
dragons in there the scary stuff and it
does make you feel like you are there
it's not like a glorified action
spectacle this movie's a very realistic
the fighting is over we're doing the
fish in the barrel thing but the
fighting is others it's not like the
first 30 minutes of Saving Private Ryan
however as much as the movie was
visually remarkable because the movie
doesn't really have character it has
people people in peril people are in
this movie characters oh no not really I
cannot tell you a name of a person in
this movie I'm pretty sure they address
the name just a lot of average-looking
white dudes with dark hair there's a
blonde dude though so what a lot of
scenes I'm like are you the same guys
that I don't I think you might be not a
lot of talking in this movie that
wouldn't be a problem and granted not a
lot of dialogue does force you to look
at other elements in the movie versus
you to use your ears for your
surroundings use your eyes more I
totally get that that's an interesting
direction to take a movie however more
dialogue would allow you to tell me more
about the characters and why I should
give a [ __ ] that I don't give a [ __ ]
about the situation the situation being
based on a true story
however this true story is wrapped up
it's in a box called a movie at that
point you need characters to grab onto
and I just didn't
onto any of these characters said know
nothing about them they have wives at
home I don't know they have a girlfriend
did they have brothers no idea are they
serial killers they [ __ ] could be I
couldn't tell you that I have no idea I
don't know about anyone in this movie so
I can't grab on because I don't know
what we're fighting for her life living
yeah that's easy to say but you need to
let me know what life this person is
going to lose out on if they don't make
it through the situation does the movie
will hop over it's like whoa it was
daytime a second ago now it's night now
it's day again granted day is followed
by night which is followed by day and
then you're like I feel like I've seen
this scene before he's doing the thing
where it's showing me the same situation
through someone else's eyes so I'm
effectively seen the same thing twice
two or three times but in a world where
all these ships look the same it's not
always clear that you see in the same
thing because the editing the movie was
kind of messy and as I said the movie is
a very realistic take of survival in a
war situation that's my way of saying
the movies pretty boring as intense as
the intense scenes that were supposed to
be intense were intense when the
intensity was going down oh sure the
movie is not that most of the movie is
things are progressing forward with very
little dialogue and as realistic as you
could say that is that's like someone
making a police movie like a cop movie
the most realistic cop movie ever and
we're supposed to like it because it's
realistic even if it's 90% paperwork in
the precinct because that is most of
what a cops life is that would be pretty
[ __ ] boring realistic doesn't
necessarily make good that all depends
on why you go for movies it all depends
on why you're going to this movie and as
much as I and I'm very sure every review
and review were is going to say the
movie looks great that's not enough for
me and it's never been enough for me to
say a movie looks great a great looking
movie doesn't make for a good movie
that's like saying I have the greatest
girlfriend ever because she looks great
yeah but what else the link would tell
me about her tell me about her past her
hopes her dreams what's in there if I
can't tell you that means I have a
pretty boring girlfriend guys in the end
this is one of those moments we have to
understand why we are here and we have
to be okay with that are you here to
hear me validate your opinion on a movie
or at least validate what you hope a
movie is going to be or are you here to
hear my honest opinion on the movie and
am I here to see validation in the
comments section or am I here to give
you my honest opinion on a movie
hopefully it's the honest opinion one
because that's all I can give you and
that's what this is it Dunkirk looked
great had some scenes of intensity that
I enjoyed Mark Rylance completely stands
out in the movie he's the one I actually
was
you kind of have a story but in the end
the movie was slow it was very ambitious
but very unfocused that's why in the
beginning of this video I said I get it
I'm a [ __ ] weirdo because apparently
I'm supposed to love this movie and when
you're a small movie reviewer in 2009
starting out on YouTube people tend to
like it when you go against Rotten
Tomatoes and go against the credit but
wouldn't you get a bit of a following it
starts to piss people off so we'll see
what happens alright guys so Dunkirk
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever he's about comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]